this is a production of Cornell
University
we're just going to win it here without
slides for a little bit so the idea for
the seminar came from a class that Mike
and I are co-teaching this semester
called wine culture which is part of the
university courses initiative so we
talked about how wine and people have
interacted over thousands of years and
one thing that's been going on over
thousands of years is that people have
been filtering or misrepresenting wine
we're back even to the ancient texts
which mike is going to talk a little bit
about so before we go on because the
title slide does acknowledge to people
who have really helped us with this
Gavin Sachs associate professor in food
science who's our wine chemist is here
somewhere oh there is way at the back
and back Brzezinski who is one of his
students and is our wine counterfeit ER
for today because we do have a tour TN
will try these a real burgundy and a
counterfeited burgundy that Beth had
worked on for you to try so my next
slide is a table that is adapted from
Gavin's upcoming textbook on wine
chemistry about all the different kinds
of wine fraud and we're going to be
focusing in on a couple here one is
mislabeling because those are our the
bid closes that you tend to hear a bed
in the news and and people write about
and we'll talk a little bit about
adulteration because that is one of the
lines that we have for you today but
there have been many other types of
misrepresentation that happens in the
wine world and some of them you may have
heard of for example in 2006 a huge case
broke that Gallo had purchased about
three and a half million gallons of what
was supposed to be Pinot Noir from the
Languedoc region and in France and it
ended up building Berlo and that only
had become clear when a couple of
officials noticed that there was more
Pinot Noir that was sold to gallo then
was produced in the region itself a few
other more popular ones that have come
up is you may have heard in the night to
lose in 1987 i believe it was there were
a number of deaths in italy where
some producers were using water and
methanol adding a little bit of wine to
it and then selling that as a table wine
and I think 17 people died and and many
more were injured and that cuz there was
a case in Austria where they were adding
in I i think was daya there's a glycol
substance right Gavin it's on my slide
slide thank you to increase the body of
wines so this is something that that
happens quite frequently and the ability
of the wine world to pick it up really
depends on whether they're anticipating
something like that is going to happen
is there are a number of analytical
techniques that are a possibility but
not all wines are of course going to be
tested for those and so really whether
we're talking about something that's
been added when it's not supposed to be
there or misrepresenting it usually only
comes to the forefront when something
goes wrong or or it really stands out to
to someone so on that note I will turn
it over to Mike and I have to give you
the microphone because we're tipping
okay let me just I'm gonna pick up the
slides but I also let me set the scene
for you I don't know how much most of
you know about Rome or why you'd even
look at ancient Rome for things but once
upon a time Rome was a village in Italy
about the size of elegant new york just
about the same size i was founded in the
year 753 BC that's more or less with the
archaeology confirms and in time it grew
to become a world empire when it
collapsed in the 5th century BC we
entered what used to be called the Dark
Ages nobody uses that term anymore even
though it's totally appropriate life got
much worse for everybody in Europe and
then all the other trade routes and
things but before then before Rome
collapse people had lives not totally
different in some ways from our own in
material ways they flush toilets for
example they had seminar rooms just like
this they had no power just like this
they did have oil lamps but they had
granite countertops some of the finer
things people like and they had a
massive trade route that went all around
the ancient world starting in the third
century BC more or less the Romans began
cultivating wine our grape
systematically to produce wine they got
the
needs from Carthage which was the rival
empire in North Africa in Tunisia today
that they crushed and by the time we
enter what's called the Classical Age of
Rome which is right around the Year Zero
we know a lot about their day-to-day
lives we know a lot about some of the
personalities I'm about to be able to
show you a slide perhaps about one of
their most famous politicians so again
just to set the stage I say the Year
Zero there is no Year Zero but that was
the year roughly one that a guy named
Jesus was born so if you've heard of
this guy you were square in the center
of classical Roman civilization two
centuries before two centuries after in
the year 63 BC there was a famous Roman
consul named Cicero so console was
basically the president of ancient Rome
they had two of them every year but in
this year there was this guy Cicero and
who was a lot like Barack Obama he came
from no special political background no
connections he was out from the
provinces he was not favored to win
whatsoever but he did win and he crushed
to conspiracy to overthrow the state
that same year so he became a very very
famous guy he was also famous for
telling jokes so after he died somebody
decided to collect Cicero's most famous
jokes and so that's what I want to start
with there is this dialogue that we have
by a guy named Mike robious doesn't
really matter that guy is but he says it
supposed to be a dinner party where
everybody sitting around drinking wine
and the narrator says I'm surprised
you've all been quiet about Cicero's
jokes which proved him as eloquent is
everything else he ever said if it seems
right unprepared to repeat the Cicero
knee ingests I remember so now he's
going to pick out one of Cicero's best
jokes of all time so this is what I just
read you he says I'm going to give you a
hilarious joke from Cicero so here's
what he says when everybody appeared
ready to listen him he said when Cicero
dying with some guy named Emma sipis and
his host offered him a rather middling
wine and said drink this 40-year old
polaire nian Cicero replied it carries
its age well so this little joke will
tell you a lot about Roman society think
about it for a second what's going on
Cicero was a very very impressive guy
you know
god I don't know the president over to
your party the host offers him a rather
middling wine some of you have probably
good ideas what that would be and he
says drink this 40-year old fool air
nyan well what do you need to know full
air nyan was the best wine of classical
antiquity the most expensive the most
prized the most delicious stuff grown in
the region around Naples you can still
buy stuff called polar nyan but in my
experience not all that great so
probably we're not drinking the same
thing it carries its age well what's the
point why is it funny yeah what do you
say Gavin
it could be comes across yeah in the
sense whatever he's drinking it's not a
forty-year-old Fellaini in that somebody
has brought out some cheap wine and
served it to him and whatever it is it's
not the stuff that the label says so
they labeled their wines just like we
did they had different brands and
prestigious and all the same thing and
the host tried to get away with like
serving the cheap stuff and got caught
in this case we have a few instances of
this there's been a Pompeii some of you
surely have been to pompeii pompeii is a
city near Naples a Roman city and the
Year 79 AD Vesuvius the volcano next to
it exploded and dumped ash all over the
whole thing totally preserved it so it
started being excavated about 300 years
ago and you can go there today in fact
the supervisor was just here last week
give us a talk and so you have a total
fossilized view of what life looked like
in Italy in this room in town two
thousand years ago and some people have
gone around they've collected the
graffiti scratched on two walls and
stuff so there's a tavern there and if
you go there I have the Latin here on
the left and then the English on the
right so head Donei this would be a
woman's name says for one penny you can
drink wine at this tavern for two
pennies you can drink the best wine and
four for you can drink phulera nyan so
you see a gradation in price but this
touches on something justine just said
there's absolutely no way on earth that
a cheap tavern like this in Pompeii
would have full Ernie and deserve
there's not that much for learning to go
around so you presumably you'd go in and
pay your four cents and drink something
that they told you was full air nyan but
you're sure you're not getting the real
thing so we could tell that they were
being dishonest about that stuff back
then there's also a very very very
famous novel from antiquity the first
and oldest novel in Western civilization
called the satyricon some of you may
have read this a different point today
you translated the billionaire's dinner
party here are some recent translations
gives you an idea from the cover what
you're looking at these are satyrs the
little goat like creatures that always
follow around Dionysus the Roman and
Greek god of wine singing music and that
sort of thing this is set in the first
century AD right around the same time
the zoo
exploded and it tells the story whoops
I'll get to this in a second it tells
the story of a nouveau riche guy he just
made a billion bucks and the Roman
equivalent of facebook or something like
that and so he wants to throw a party
and show off all is well I stuck this
slide in the wrong place but I can stop
here full air nyan by the way according
to the ancient authors from the same
time they say it was a white wine
possibly 30 proof this is the law I
picked up at various places and
according to an ancient Authority it's
the only one that catches fire when a
flame is applied to it and I just got an
email from you Gavin the circuitous Lee
about this if this is impossible right
you can't light wine on fire but we are
they that that doesn't mean anything to
them
temperature to be played with a hot
grill with interrupted
uh yea though they did both they
sometimes put snow in the line
okay so this is interesting the guy who
wrote this plenty very famous because he
/ he preserves all this lore about
growing grapes in Italy at the time and
when some of the stuff was rediscovered
in the Renaissance people said these
techniques still work he almost
certainly never tried to light this
stuff on fire he was the Wikipedia of
ancient Rome he just collected knowledge
without a whole lot of regard to whether
it was true or not and put it all on
this famous encyclopedia we got so
that's the full Ernie and this is the
stuff they're always celebrating this is
the the bottle of what you can buy today
but let me get back to the satyricon if
you know the great gatsby I hope you
know those the protagonist is based on
the protagonist of the satyricon we know
this when f scott fitzgerald before he
publish a great gatsby he wrote a
preliminary novel called a tremolo and
so he makes it perfectly clear that
Gatsby is based on that and I brought
this into our wine culture class to try
and give them an idea of what a crazy
over-the-top party would be today but it
doesn't resonate as much with the
students today I think as some other
characters you could think of this is
gas we hear the word oh do I is it still
in there let me get it how do I go
forward and backwards honey I just want
to shoot too far I don't want to take up
too much of your time I thought I pulled
it out maybe I think I pull it out there
no that's okay okay hey okay so true
malkio I I liken this in our class to an
episode of MTV Cribs if you've seen the
show he has this phenomenal house and
the novel is about these two guys random
guys were travelling through Italy and
they finagle an invitation to this guy's
house for a dinner party where they're
going to be drinking wine so the novel
is what happens to these guys when they
get to the house and they walk in and
according to the narrator one of these
young guys he says Trimalchio the owner
of this house have been smothered in
perfume and was already being rubbed
down not with linen towels but with
bathrobes of the finest wool as this was
going on three masseurs said drinking
full air nyan in front of him though
quarrel
they spilled most of it and Trimalchio
said they were drinking his health so
this tells us a few things about Roman
culture again our Greek Roman culture
one is said in the ancient world you
would you would toast somebody's health
by pouring a libation you would pour a
little wine onto the ground this is not
totally unknown today people do these
things you put a little on the ground
here though what do you think as you
read this passage is going on they walk
in and they see this guy's house this
huge house and their host has just come
out of the Roman baths he's being rubbed
down not with linen towels but with
bathrobes of cashmere you would say it's
crazy over the top right this is not the
kind of thing most people do and so
these guys where they see him getting
massage from three people and they're
drinking for learning and one this is
the help drinking for learning and
they're spilling it because they're
bickering and the host is totally
unconcerned he says other pouring
libations tonight so the novel is making
it clear it's a satire of nouveau riche
people who are trying to put on a good
impression nobody really does this in
the real world but we do have parallels
to this for example this gentleman who
the students did not know by sight the
Millennials don't know Puff Daddy of
course this resonates with me but that's
Cristal he's pouring out on the ground
wearing his fur presumably he doesn't do
this every day but this is the kind of
thing you do for media photos so that's
what this novel is about it's basically
the same thing whatever those guys are
drinking in the novel it's not going to
be a real polar nyan later on in the
party they're having dinner so they're
all they're all reclining this is the
way you ate at dinner parties in the
interworld so the reclining on one side
and the narrator says carefully sealed
wine bottles were immediately brought
out to us their necks were labeled for
lair nyan console a penius 100 years old
so while we were examining the labels
Trimalchio clapped his hands and said
with a sigh wine has a longer life than
us poor folks so let's wet our whistles
why I'm is life I'm giving you real
opeenion I didn't put out such good
stuff yesterday although the company was
much better class so there are a few
jokes we know here because of our Roman
history
so for learning of course is going to be
the very best stuff the console
remembers the president of ancient Rome
there are two of these guys every year
and that's how the Romans dated their
years so if you wanted to know the year
64 or 63 rather bc the roman would say
that was the year that Cicero was consul
so the year that this guy Opie miyase
Wisconsin was a famous vintage in
ancient Rome the most famous vintage and
it was the most expensive line what we
know is that the time period that this
novel is set is much later than a
hundred years after conta de this guy
who penius was consul so this is part of
the joke the host has been sold some
wine labeled polarian with a year that
absolutely does not match what it should
be so the novel is making clear that the
the protagonist is being satirize he's
too stupid so he went to the sparrows
and they sold them some coca-cola and a
champagne bottle or something like that
uh and i'm going to with that i think
that's enough for the ancien where i'm
going to pass it off to you Justine to
tell us about how it hasn't really
changed right so it hasn't really
changed because we still have people who
want to spend a lot of money on what are
considered trophy bottles of wine and
that's how we get into trouble so how
many of you have read this book it's an
amazing book the billionaire's vinegar
okay only two okay it's really good
pillage turner I you should read it
because the movie is coming out the
books always better than the movie you
know how that goes and it will start
Matthew McConaughey and this is the
story of a guy named hardly rawdon's dog
so Hardy Rawdon stock was a German
citizen and he was a manager of a couple
of sort of mid-level pop bands and then
he got really into the wine soon and
started purchasing a lot of really
expensive well-known wines then he
started hosting his absolutely lavish
tastings at castles at hotels and he
would invite dignitaries mean had
amazing wine list and so he was able to
get big melons there
from the wine world the influential
names like Robert Parker jr. you know
Robert Parker jr. who is the number one
wine critic in the world now we talk
about parkerized ocean of wines as
people trying to milk wine to to appease
his palate jancis robinson the very
famous master of wine british wine
writer Michael Broadbent from Christie's
Auction House so these are some of the
very top wine people and he would invite
them to his lavish tastings but normally
at toasting zwi spit our wines and he
did not allow spitting at his tasting so
the rule was that you had to drink the
wine to fully appreciate just how good
the wine was so he would have people
drink the wine and then he would save
the very best until the last so he
started hosting it will be 11 mm and
then at 11pm he would bring out these
bottles that everybody was waiting for
of course everybody was reasonably
enumerated at the time and so when he
brought out these bottles for example
that were considered playful akshara so
this was proven at the root pest that
had afflicted most of the wine world
including bordeaux and burgundy in the
Middleton hundreds he would bring out
wines from the earlier to hundreds but
no one was really in a condition to
truly evaluate these wines so but he was
getting very famous and people loved to
go to his testings he sold a lot of
wines but then a couple of people
started to get suspicious because in the
wine world an even better trophy wine
than an amazing vintage from Bordeaux or
burgundy for example is to show up with
a larger format bottle so he started
showing up actually with Imperials which
aren't on here Imperials are six liter
bottles from some amazing vintages and a
couple of people so these were a shadow
cultures from from Bordeaux a couple
people said I don't think that had
Imperials for those vintages but you
know everyone's having a great time if
there's two listings and that sort of
thing so so whisper started uh and then
this
showed up on the market does anyone know
these bottles the Thomas Jefferson
bottles yeah this was big news in the
wide world so Hardy rod and stock claims
that he got a call from someone I
tearing down an older home in Paris and
behind a brick wall he found a stash of
old bordeaux's so these are our labeled
as you consider 720 before 1700 27
they're labeled as first growth so the
very top level of Bordeaux wines so
Lafitte for example if you dispelled
with only 12 now and they're labeled to
Joel to signify that they may have
belonged to Thomas Jefferson so why
would Thomas Jefferson have wines in
Paris well Thomas Jefferson spent a lot
of time in Paris who was my
understanding is the French envoy over
there he loved buying Bordeaux expensive
Bordeaux and when he returned to America
who continued to purchase a lot of
Bordeaux he ordered not only for himself
but for George Washington as well but
what he did do was he kept impeccable
records of everything who had ever
ordered when she got the delivery what
the wines were like and and that sort of
thing so one of these bottles first
shows up at christie's auction house
from from Hardy rotten stock and the
head of wine at christie's auction house
is a guy named Michael Broadbent who's
very well known in the world of wine and
he does his best to authenticate the
wine she touched it to his bottle guy
and the bubble guy said yeah that's a
little bottle and it tooks it to his
engraving guy who said yeah happy
engraving looks pretty old and so he
goes yeah I believe this is a 707 Thomas
Jefferson wine and so they put it up for
auction the auction goes absolutely
bananas the Forbes family buys the
bottle for over a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars this is night to
another five
so then hardly run suck has a couple
more bottles there go out of that sort
of thing and then these four more
bottles show up and they have sold this
guy did I don't know who this guy is
yeah yeah okay if one of the Koch
brothers but he is he is not one of
those two Koch brothers he's not part of
the American for prosperous future or
whatever they're super PAC is he was the
litigious brother he's the one who is
always suing them about the family
business so this is a guy named Bill
Koch and this is his private wine cellar
in his home in public which tells you
something about him uh and so these for
Thomas Jefferson bottles get sold
through an auction house to Bill Koch
and so he's super excited and he was
going to put on a toast phone and he
calls Monticello Thomas Jefferson's home
in museum and says oh I'd really like
you to write something up about these
bottles from you to display at this
toasting and then said those are from
Thomas Jefferson we have records of
every wines who's bought and he never
even labeled anything to lose if he put
his initials on something it was just
too Joe these are not Thomas Jefferson
bottles and who says well how come you
never said this before and they said oh
no one asked we had reports but no one
ever could've does to authenticate these
bottles so Bill Koch think what you want
to bet the Koch brothers you've actually
turned into a huge crusader who is done
I think a big favor for the wine world
by hiring a team that suppose for
privately to go and sniff out
counterfeit wines because his
counterfeit wines are are really
significant and are very much damaging
the fine wine market so who has sued
every major auction house for selling
him fake wines he's tried to go after a
hearty run stock but hasn't been able to
get him because of jurisdiction issues
and what actually ended up happening
with the Thomas Jefferson bottles is
that eventually
they were able to test them so there are
a number of just different testing
options but one thing you usually have
to do is go in and took a sample of the
wine which if you've paid a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for the bottle
you never want anyone to do right
because that just ruins the bottle and a
lot of these wines are actually not
bought to enjoy their purchased so that
those can be sold for investment and
that sort of thing but there was a
reasonably new method where the test for
the presence of cesium-137 so Susie him
is a radioactive compound that didn't
exist until a nuclear bomb was exploded
on earth and so what they can tell we
can't tell whether they belong to Thomas
Jefferson they can tell whether they are
pre-1945 wines and endued the Thomas
Jefferson bottles do test positive for
building prune 1945 both the wine and
the glass since then bill cokes tim has
found the guy who says who didn't
graving on the bottles with a dental
tool so that Christie's Auction House
should have known that that these were
faked and the lawsuits are still
continue but some of the fallout from
this is that this is a very very famous
book by Michael Broadbent who is ahead
of of Christie's Auction House and so
it's a it says 15 years of posting
through centuries of wine so he was the
world expert on 1700 early 1800 wines
and the problem is that a lot of those
wines that he wrote about were sourced
from hearted rotten stock and so this
book that everyone was essentially using
as a Bible for vintage wines that ends
up that at least a proportion of those
wines were completely soaked but when
you think about it it's easy to fill
late seventeen hundred lines because who
knows what those are supposed to taste
like right absolutely no one although
it's suspicious when excuse me you read
some of those reviews and who says oh
brutal and
leader and Mike from the second hundreds
it's vinegar vinegar definitely on the
suspicious side more recently ah this is
a character you might know an indie
musician who was living in Los Angeles
and his name I was rooted Colonel Irwin
and and he is now a very famous
counterfeiter and rather than hardy
rotten stock was counterfeiting really
old bottles that nobody knew what they
were supposed to taste like this guy I
was truly an artist with an absolutely
amazing palate and so what he did was he
was filtering bottles that a lot of
people knew what were supposed things
were supposed to taste like so
Burgundy's for example where his big
things is Burgundy's from the twenties
through to the 1970s so there are a lot
of people in the world who know what
those wines are supposed to smell like
and are supposed to taste like so he
showed up very young guy in his early
twenties shows up on the Los Angeles to
them and is buying tons of wine at
auctions millions of dollars worth of
wine all the time doesn't say where is
my new time from family businesses is is
all he'll say and he started putting on
lavish postings for a select group of
people the wine critics have kind of
learned at this point I got to stop
going to those things because I get
fooled by them but but he had a few
select toasters and they would get
together for example at this Los Angeles
restaurant called crew and they were
taste for four toes straighten and have
a bill of you know two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars at the end of it he
would just put it on his credit card
very nonchalantly and then he would ask
for all of the bottles to be shipped to
his house all of the empty bottles of
things that have toasted which is a
little odd right why do you want the
empty bottles of wines your tested so
then he'd go around town and do all of
these testings and always ask that these
bottles be shipped to him and one time I
I kiss broke and he got really really
upside of case of empty bottles and the
restaurant was like why are you all it
said Chester to the savanna three
bottles well what are you
was doing was a was an incredible
operation in his basement when the
police finally got to him so the guy on
that on the lower left is a guy named
Laurel Paso and he is from he was a
burgundy wine maker and he raised the
alert when a bunch of wines were up for
auction in new york city that had been
had come from the collection of rudy
kurniawan and they were from vintages
that Paul saw had never produced so they
have a very famous wine called close
LaRoche for example and they didn't
start producing it until I think the
Fortas and he had put on vintages from
the 20's through the third who's he is
another famous one eye closed to new and
again he put on vintages that weren't
there had never been produced so who
started asking some questions showed up
and stopped an auction the wines were
were withdrawn and when they finally got
to his basement what he had were a whole
bunch of labels he'd felt all of these
old bottles from wine teeth actually
tasted and what he was doing was just
mixing together newer or cheap wines to
come up with these older wines so he had
recipes for example written out and
tacked to the wall if you want tomoka dr
salut from 1924 or some vintage he
wanted you can put in a third of a
bottle of oxidized Bordeaux a third of a
bottle of Napa CAD and some 1956
keyboard oh that he was picking up and
then when they started investigating him
a parent he was missing some strange
purchases like buying a bunch of
Burgundy from the 30s and 40s in bulk
vintages that no one wanted no one
thought they were going to get rid of
and he was buying gallons and gallons
and gallons of them but he was truly she
had an incredible palate and he was able
to produce these wines and full
collectors who really knew what these
wines were supposed to smell like and
suppose
to taste like so he is now in jail for
fraud for for fraud wire fraud and mail
fraud and a bunch of other things all
relating to sale of these wines
estimates of the fig wine knows who's
put on the market range from about 100
million to 500 million but it's not that
here in North America when we're talking
about the fine wine market so usually
then we're thinking wines above say five
hundred or a thousand dollars a bottle
probably about twenty percent of those
are fit visit estimate over in Alicia
and the Chinese are big purchasers a
Bordeaux right now the accent is that
about fifty percent of the market and
Paul so from Bergen do says that the
percent of pre night to know the Bergen
do these are fig when you're purchasing
them on the market so this is a huge
problem and it comes from wine be
reaching that trophy's status stage
where people want to have it splurge on
on the wine and very often those don't
get actually drunk and part of it is
that it can be easy to do if you have a
good palate you can pick up these
bottles on those there this is a chateau
hope real which is a first growth so you
can buy the bottle for fifty dollars a
bottle and then if you put something in
there someone will actually pay for you
can get between about these are 19 6 26
items you can get between about 500 and
a thousand dollars per bottle if you can
fool people and it appears that it's not
all that hard to do that so I so huge
problem in the wine world now wine is
getting financialized many of you have
probably seen the big short Don and I
were talking about this the other day
there was a business that is now under
investigation in berkeley they were
selling futures on wine so right after
the vintage like at this time of year
you can buy futures on bordeaux from
2015 so you're sure to hedging your bets
on whether the wine will be expensive or
or not expensive and they were selling
all these futures without actually
owning futures and
bottles ever existing so it's going to
be an issue in terms of investment as
well so I to show you how is rid of two
ought to do this I asked Gavin and Beth
to fill a one so we have some wine to
the back and so why not i'll ask you to
get up and get them now they're labeled
alien booth took one is one booth come
back to your suit and then I'll ask Beth
to tell you how I familiy them I will
say one of them is adulterated but
completely safe we've given them to a
number of students before no deaths and
no methanol involved so if you could
grab a wine in booth done
can we call on you to talk briefly about
how you mode one of these wines it's
urchins are outlines up here we just
some Gavin and I and on my team daniela
who work with me we did comprise
beforehand but what we do is start with
really a very mediocre under ten dollar
bottle of overall wine that's from
Portugal made with traditional
Portuguese grace and it has a bad for
Channel might even infestation so it has
a lot of funk to it then thermals great
for about 40 degrees so these for 10
days to put it in an incubator let it
sit there and then after that fine with
PDP um so we do normally the maximum
pppp that you do about one gram per year
what's pvp p oh sorry the finding agent
polyvinyl we're getting allowed to poly
for Oleg um Holly pyrrolidone so it's um
what it does it strips away a lot of the
color
one so you just we're doing ten times
the absolute maximum of a mouth that you
normally add so you just do that we
filter it out and then add back some
color using caramel food coloring which
is like a brownish
yeah yeah and so as wine tent right
let's look at morning for kids so going
try your wines and we'll have a vote and
also so if you guys got dad will mine or
anyone so if you want to order a first
or me first whatever you like with it
note which one do you finish the meal
Gordo and I should say so the real one
is me tonight okay let's vote so why do
suggest we're going to close our eyes so
that not everything who's the one person
here and run with it subscribe but if
your hand if you thought that it was did
you get a within this okay and quickly
here to do that for you with system and
only yeah it's tight but it okay you can
open your eyes it's talk about a bunch
of you we're not voting for the county
no I a was the real bored out so how
about you do that
come on get with the guidelines and
their vines started for the trophy truly
they don't know what to expect and older
virgos are pretty [ __ ] in many cases
Richard I come I haven't got a few of
just not fake vs real versus aged Gordo
marriage burgundy versus newer say two
three four what I don't think I've ever
done a preference testing with people
who know something about why the not a
lot I think I've ever seen a majority
prefer the older wine old why drunken
kind of weird there's a read and it's
rare and that the man side is what makes
no or supply sighs what makes them more
expensive its butt head to head it
tastes up I don't think I've ever seen
even more like ten percent go from first
a 15 year old Bordeaux over one that's
45 years old right and i think you have
read that simplistic working with a
chateau latour on first growth not too
forward i think it was so it's the old
the oldest one I've ever had the most
expensive one I've ever had it was
selling it's time for close to four
thousand dollars per model and it was
the worst one like it was it was
reasonably and leathery and slightly
vinegar
the question asked my dad who collect
stamps is it is that 1912 stamp here is
that mail envelopes a lot better because
it's so expensive it says that's not the
reason why he wants it um that wraps it
up we have a few minute second question
I have there been more advanced
techniques that have been developed in
case of years for sleeping out of a time
ah so yes you can go more in-depth Texas
certainly the student once or seven it's
one that came around because of God you
give to try to identify older line but
my impression is that that mostly is
that people have not a bit developed new
analytical techniques but they've gone
to develop a wonderful technician and
brothels and so I didn't um you know
there is like 11 problem neck that shows
up the oneworld alliance is it rids go
to be silly won't mind sleepin so
yeah well you want to sound kappa
aberrantly so young but you go to the
Central Valley and kind of one tenth of
the price and then label it and I'm
giving you isotope analysis or elemental
analysis for example map to be
determined what religion so yeah new
techniques you're going around again
often you have to sample the wine would
have had and what is expensive older
wine so like what do we do about wine
consumption patterns in each of grown
compared till today we have any video
that make sense well sure when Tom this
was actually the very the very first
lecture that we had in our class was the
chair of my department is a Bronze Age
archaeologist came and showed us that it
was basically an old world global trade
and lines far back as you can go so and
the height of my was being shipped all
over the Roman Empire and just for point
of reference the Roman Empire at his
height in 212 ed was started in England
went down to the Sahara Desert off to
the Rhine River and all the way out to
around everything on the in between that
except for chunks of Germany is part of
remsen was a huge market oxidant than it
would have been just
how much of you
on average know that's where to say they
drank it differently than we do today so
in classical Greece at the symposium
people drank the wine cut with Walter so
you mix for parts of our one part of on
and in Rome they typically drank two
parts of water at on the border line and
that is their normal local consumption
so what we just did here what we do here
in the United States is something they
thought all the barbarians so basically
it becomes hard measure even investor
it's a good question yep plans have you
stumble across anything about how if
broad was indeed not commonplace it
occurred how authentication was done
outside of having a label on a seal is
there anything else that a person could
do during Roman times as a means to
evaluate was there in the ancient world
I don't see how you can do anything of
course they had no microscopes oh no and
of course the ground a bit of forgery in
anything but especially things like
artistic I think is that as soon as you
go on tentative some of the summit
somebody where did you get accustomed to
you know the new sod so you see this in
our district with somebody authenticate
support anything and say oh that you
know that looks
the rest of the artists out but I guess
if they artists can do that and the next
forgery come on say well I've been
exporting so this was a big problem of
Vermeer paintings when they were being
fortunes big scam was some years ago but
now you start to adjust your path it
would happen the blind right now to try
to be very much make more deaths that
must be recorded basic so back then
okay I was thinking I lost on to
chemical means but for presenting me to
like record keeping where they were
respecting something besides just a
label on the bottle but they were
expecting a bill blading or something
like that we don't have any records they
count them we know they've got the right
but we don't have no I think the only
thing was that amphora were shipped
differently depending on where in a wine
was from right oh maybe that is called
beyond sore legs Batista the remark for
video cameras of the Emperor worship
differently the transfer Emperor went
all around the Mediterranean so they
were standard size that cargo ships
today so I don't know they might be
different I've experienced that they're
different should push and that sometimes
you can identify where I one came from
this side should be after I've
eventually started looking different
aircraft
the questions purchase did you mentioned
that i forget what what specific time
period but up to eighty percent of a
certain type of one is period is
considered potentially counterfeit that
right yeah yes so ah Loretta Costello
food is now started a good burgundy moon
who is fighting counterfeit versions his
claim is that ility percenter pre-1980
important for a bourbon minute sorry I
don't think you can support that with
yoga but they do have some of red
examples where you know they've gone on
social media and how we got the number
of people that said they are drinking
you know what 50th anniversary of DRC
and more people drunk at odds with your
anniversary I guess my question is does
that segment of the market then freeze
up like if it's potentially that high
are people still there skating and
buying those bottles or or is it still a
very lucrative abortion industry to the
end it's still ah it's still pretty
because they're up here to be and
someone came shopping at that madam
chair there are always appear to be new
collectors with a lot of muscle coming
on board that don't have the experience
to know counterfeit wine and know
whether and so so if a collector is
experienced they will divide of reliable
sources often houses that even though
that we saw you know Christian
conservatives so many other ones but
there's still this market where people
go and buy from private collectors and
that's one thing that that they were
never able to track is with attorney for
new one if you sold a lot in privately
but they didn't really have a record of
that and there's also an embarrassment
factor is that people don't want to come
out instead if it had so a lot of people
should quiet and just for that line
havin a question more for Beth why do we
have a cordon of wine counterfeiting
hope we do not have a lunch counter for
the food but that is better take that
off with your CD wine tasting I don't
know I mean if you can any ate all these
people who are knowledgeable about it
confused about what wine they're keeping
something about what it's more of an art
so when we're talking about white roses
um so it's hard to say but I can include
a cubic studies for example it was
ascended from a couple of years ago
where the good people with a second seed
or two lines or is not
wine and it did green at our eyes well
one and they found that if you need to
have a not be dollar bottle of wine your
brief MRIs really quite different
comparative you have a ten dollar bottle
one the problem is from the exact when
there was a study where I served wine it
was done in the UK land so i think would
use transit dollars it was between five
and fifty dollars a bottom and people
would have been better off flipping a
coin to try and kick what they thought
the model price was rather than I came
to find so I you know Kevin your peoples
really high in mind hard to say to you I
think there's a statement of people out
there who are super toasters and have
incredible tips and members who can
recognize these lines and really tell
them apart we're going to have to write
things up but i want to thank just
fascinating lecture and for operating
under effort this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu